-Welcome back.
You look gorgeous.
Thanks for being here.
-Thank you.
Back in the studio.
-In person!
-I know.
-I haven't seen you --
We Zoomed.
-We Zoomed a couple times,
yes, during lockdown.
-Yeah, thank you for doing that
for us.
I appreciate that.
-It felt like I was sort of
a part of history.
Like, I don't know how many
people have done
"The Tonight Show" over Zoom.
-It was weird times.
-But I feel like I'm a part of
an exclusive group.
-You are.
Yeah, you're part of the fam.
-Yeah.
-We love having -- thanks for
playing "Catch Phrase," too.
That was intense.
-Oh, I love games like that.
-You do?
-"Catch Phrase," "Heads Up."
You know, I make people
on the set play those games
all the time.
I think they get sick of it.
-We celebrated, I hugged Conan,
I could feel his heart beating.
[ Laughter ]
Honestly, about to have
a heart attack.
Intense.
-It is.
It's very --
It's a lot of adrenaline.
-Slip N' Slide --
that was unbelievable.
-I still can't believe
you got "cyborg."
-Here's the thing.
Like, when we play that game,
you often forget that you're
able to be physical, as well.
-Yeah.
-It's true.
-But how did you get "cyborg"?
-Dude, we were locked in.
-We were.
We were at that point.
[ Laughter ]
-"Cyborg"?
I would never get that.
I would've lost the game,
"cyborg."
Dude, "It's a bird game"?
[ Laughter ]
I can't even --
We'll talk some other time.
But first, let's talk about you.
Let's talk about "Westworld,"
please.
It's finally back.
It's coming back Sunday.
-It's back.
We're back, baby.
Yeah, season four.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
Fans are waiting two years
for this new season.
And your character, Dolores,
died at the end of last season.
-Spoiler alert.
[ Laughs ]
-We can say that.
-Yeah, catch up, guys, come on.
-Yeah, exactly, yeah.
But you're still on the show.
Who are you playing on the show
this season?
-This season, I am playing
a character called Christina,
who is much more human, much
more vulnerable, very nerdy.
She's a writer
and a video-game programmer.
-Wow.
Okay.
I love the show because, really,
the writing
takes it to the next level.
-Yes.
-And you don't really know
what's gonna happen.
There's always a good twist.
And you don't know -- "Wait.
Is that person dead,
or, no, they're back,
or are they a robot?"
-You never really know
if you're dead on "Westworld."
'Cause clearly,
they can just bring you
right back as somebody else.
It doesn't matter, really.
-Yeah, yeah.
And James Marsden is back.
-James Marsden is back!
Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I mean, he was gone
for an entire season.
-He was gone
They really wanted
to fake people out.
And I was so dedicated
to keeping the secret
that I lied to my own mother.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
-Really?
-Whose dog is named Teddy,
by the way.
So this was a big deal for her.
And she was like,
"Wait, wait. Is it real?"
And I was like, "Yeah, man.
I don't know.
I mean, it's 'Westworld,'
so you never really know,
but, like, I'm pretty sure
he's dead, dude."
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh!
-And so, yeah, yeah,
we had to stretch it out
as long as possible.
-I love you do that.
What can we say?
'Cause I don't want to give
any spoilers
besides what I just said
that anyone died
could come back.
But what can we say about
the new season of the show?
-Nothing.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, really you can't, right?
This Sunday.
-This Sunday, it takes place
in New York --
in a futuristic New York City.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's where we do our show.
-So...
-I could've been in this.
-A cyborg version of you...
-Yes.
-...should've been in season 4.
-Who do I gotta call? JJ?
-Just your head on the desk.
-Oh, my God, how creepy.
Yeah, hologram head?
[ Laughter ]
It's always good and well-done,
and we love it when you come on.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Evan Rachel Wood in the
new season of "Westworld."
Take a look.
♪♪
-Record pitch.
There's a young girl.
Not that young.
More like late teens.
She lives at home with her
father in the country.
[ Birds chirping ]
Scratch that -- the city.
He's a little infirmed,
so she spends
most of her time with him.
But she dreams of a bigger life
with excitement,
adventure, romance.
-I mean, come on.
That is --
-What does it all mean?
But that is --
That is the future.
-It is.
It really is.
I mean, I think, in a few years,
people will realize
that "Westworld"
was sort of a documentary.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, exactly.
I want to ask you about this.
There's a photo
that's been going around.
You're playing Madonna.
-I am playing Madonna.
-In the Weird Al biopic.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-In the Weird Al biopic, yes.
-What was your reaction
when you were asked to play her?
-Honestly, like, I thought
I was gonna take a break
for the rest of the year,
and then I got an e-mail,
and the first thing I read is,
"You've been offered the role
of Madonna,"
and I just burst out laughing.
It was like --
Like you just spit your drink
out when you read that.
You know?
Like, it's just --
You're not expecting that
on a Tuesday.
And then I was like,
"Oh, God, do I want to do this?
This is, like,
a lot of responsibility."
But it's in a comedy.
It's not a Madonna biopic.
-You don't think
you would do a Madonna --
-I think that would be
way too much pressure.
Like, I don't know.
So like, as a comedy --
-I mean, you nailed the look.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Do you -- Do you --
So, so you talk like Madonna?
How does Madonna talk?
-It was a specific Madonna.
You know,
it's early '80s Madonna.
[ As Madonna ]
And early '80s Madonna,
she really --
you know, she was very nasally,
and everything she said
was very intentional.
[ Laughter ]
And she disarms everyone
that interviews her
by sort of looking at them.
-Wow!
And have you talked to Madonna?
Does Madonna know
you're playing her?
-[ Normal voice ] No!
[ Laughter ]
-Are you scared?
-I'm a little scared.
I mean, it was like
halfway through filming,
and I just assumed -- they've
obviously cleared this with her.
And then halfway through
filming, I looked at them,
I was like, "Yeah, so you guys
obviously talked to Madonna.
How'd it go?"
And they were like...
[ Laughter ]
-"We..."
-I was like, "Oh, great.
Now -- great, thanks, guys.
You just put me on bad terms
with Madonna."
[ Laughter ]
-No, no!
Yeah, you don't want to be
on the bad side of Madonna.
-No! I love Madonna.
-Me too.
Do you get to sing
as Madonna, as well?
-No. I sang --
We had, like, a karaoke
wrap party, and I sang Madonna,
and then the director goes,
"Why didn't I make you sing
in this movie?"
-Yeah.
-I did. I can sing like Madonna.
-Yeah, I mean you --
-I have to be able to sing
like a lot of different people
'cause I have my band,
Evan + Zane, and we do
so many different genres
and so many different styles.
-We always have --
We always have
a microphone here.
-Oh, my God.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We have the best band
in the world.
Would you do it?
-Okay.
I'll do it, I'll do it.
Okay.
[ Laughing ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ They can beg,
and they can plead ♪
♪ But they can't see the light ♪
♪ 'Cause the boy
with the cold hard cash ♪
♪ Is always Mister Right ♪
♪ 'Cause we are living
in a material world ♪
♪ And I am a material girl ♪
♪ You know that we are
living in a material world ♪
♪ And I am a material girl ♪
-Wait. What? How?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
How?!
How do you do everything?
-I don't know.
-How do you do everything?
-My job.
-That was fantastic.
Do you do
any other musical impressions?
-Yeah.
Do you know any Alanis?
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-1, 2, 3!
♪ And I'm here ♪
♪ To remind you ♪
♪ Of the mess you left
when you went away ♪
♪ It's not fair ♪
♪ To deny me ♪
♪ Of the cross I bear
that you gave to me ♪
♪ You, you, you oughta know ♪
-What in the what?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
-What in the world is going on?!
What is going on?
Do you have any more?
Is that all you got?
-Let's do Janis!
Let's do Joplin!
-You do Janis Joplin?
-Yes!
-Roots, do you know, uh...
♪♪
-♪ Now come on, come on,
come on, come on ♪
♪ Yeah, take it ♪
♪ Take another little piece
of my heart now, baby ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
-♪ Break it ♪
♪ Break another little piece
of my heart, darlin', yeah ♪
-♪ Come on ♪
-♪ Have another little piece
♪ Of my heart now, baby ♪
♪ You know you got it, child,
if it makes you feel good ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Evan Rachel Wood, everybody!
Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Westworld" returns
for it's fourth season
this Sunday on HBO and HBO Max.
Harry Smith joins us
after the break.
Stick around.
♪ Have a ♪
-♪ Have another little piece
of my heart now, baby ♪
♪ Well, you know you got it ♪
Whoooa, take it!
-♪ Have a ♪
-♪ Have another little piece ♪
♪ Of my heart now, baby ♪
-♪ Oh, oh, have it♪
-♪ You know you got it
if it makes you feel good ♪